[Music]
one of the characters in ursula k le
guin's third earth sea novel the
farthest shore cobb that's his use name
haunts the novel for really about the
first two-thirds of it and he's coming
up in terms of reminiscences and
reflections on the part of get who has
actually encountered him and as the
novel goes on we
figure out that he is the person
responsible
for the wizardry the luck the skill the
craft the
life being sucked out of the world of
earthsea he's done something
and he's used magic to
do this he is drastically upset what the
mages of roe call the balance or the
equilibrium and not just within earth
sea itself but within relation to the
world of the living in earth sea and the
dry land the land of the dead and the
relations between death and life are how
that's going to come about and this
brings us to the pellish lore or the
lore of palm palm is one of the
islands of earth sea
it's got its own kind of
magic and majory going on there sorcery
and there's a lot of things that happen
in the backstory of pelham that we're
only getting hints about so ged
tells us some of this in in relation to
um aaron aaron is asking him about
alpha run and
earthsy and morid and ged says i i
actually saw her when i did the greatest
evil i have ever done
it was to her beauty i thought i turned
and i saw her for a moment i saw
alpharon
and
then aaron is going to say is it true
then the dead can be brought back into
life and made to speak to living souls
by majoring god says yes by the spells
of summoning it is in our power but it
is seldom done and i doubt that it is
ever wisely done now that's an important
point that we'll come back to
in a moment
in this the master summoner agrees with
me the the current master summoner also
if we go back to a wizard of earthsea
the old master summoner when ged was
still a student also thought that was a
bad idea as well as did ogian right he
does not use or teach the lore of palm
in which such spells are contained the
greatest of them now we get introduced
to this this other backstory character
were made by one called the grey mage of
palm a thousand years ago
he summoned up the spirits of the heroes
and mages
even areth akba to give counsel to the
lords of palm in their wars and
government so this is a great advantage
imagine if you could take advantage of
the combined wisdom
of those who have lived and died and
profit from their mistakes
get actually goes on to say however
the council of the dead is not
profitable to the living
we'll see why
in a bit palm came on evil times and the
grey mage was driven forth he died
nameless what it means to die nameless
is nobody
remembering him nobody memorializing him
once a person dies in earth's either
their true name can be spoken forth
and
used to describe them nobody knows who
this grey mage was
we will see later on
that
cobb is going to have the
staff of the gray maid she says this is
the staff of the grey mage he who
silenced narrager the master of my art
narrager was another mage back in palm
who
did some heroic deeds learning from
dragons
how to
use the true name what the true name was
of the black mage so there's a little
bit of backstory there
and so he's got this this artifact of
the gray mage and what did the grey mage
do well he developed these these spells
and so
it's not all the grey mage's lore but he
sort of speak is the pinnacle
of it and there's a lot of pelnish
lore
that is
available but one should not
use them
and
they're dangerous they're dangerous
spells to use why so get explains to us
this has to do with metaphysics and this
has to do with our own understanding
so aaron asks them is it a wicked thing
then the lore of palm and ged says no i
would call it a misunderstanding a
misunderstanding of life
death and life are like the same are the
same thing like the two sides of my hand
the palm
and the back and still the palm in the
back are not the same they can neither
be separated or mixed and then aaron
says then no one uses these spells now
and here he's going to tell us about
about cobb in just a moment but before
that he says these spells are
risky dangerous beyond any other
majority death and life are like the two
sides of my hand i said but the truth is
we do not know what life is
or what death is to claim power over
what you do not understand is not wise
nor is the end of it likely to be good
and gad will bring up his own story a
little bit later on and say
i know how much evil one man one life
can do
i've done it i've done the same evil in
the same folly of pride i opened the
door between the worlds life and death
just a crack a little crack to show that
i was stronger than death itself i was
young and i had not met death like you
it took of the strength the strength of
the archmage nemmer leia took his
mastery in his life to shut that door
you can see the mark that night left on
me on my face but him had killed
the door between the light and the
darkness can be opened it takes strength
but it can be done but to shut it is a
different story so when somebody is
using the lore of palm they're messing
around with some stuff that goes to the
very
core of existence and you know can have
a lot of repercussions
and so here's where he brings up cop
and
ged says i did see somebody who used
this lore and now notice
not only is cobb
careless
to some degree but he's also using it
for motives very different than say the
grey mage was the grey mage is
counseling kings and ged actually wants
to you know engage in this wizard's
battle back in the uh wizard of earthsea
so it's his pride in the case of cobb
he's doing it for more tawdry
reasons
pride is part of it but he's also doing
it for for money he's doing it for
show
so he summons souls of the dead and his
god tells us
here we go uh he lived in havnor they
accounted him a mere sorcerer but in
native power he was a great mage he made
money from his art showing any who paid
him whatever spirit they asked to see
dead wife or husband or child
filling his house with unquiet shadows
of old centuries the fair women of the
days of kings i saw him summon from the
dry land my own old master who was
archmage and my youth namely for a mere
trick to entertain the idol so some
people are coming to him because they're
like hey i want to see my dead family
members again some are like hey
entertain us and so he brings
nemerley there and ged sees this ged is
to say the least
not happy about this and we learned
something about him
in the process
he says that great soul came at his call
like a dog to heal i was angry and
challenged him i was not archmage then
saying you compel the dead to come into
your house will you come into with me to
their to theirs and i made him go it
with me into the dry land though he
fought me with his will and changed his
shape and wept aloud when nothing else
would do aaron says did you kill him and
he says no no i i did this instead i
made him follow me into the land of the
dead and return with me from it
he was afraid he who summoned the dead
to him so easily was more afraid of
death than any man i ever knew
at the wall of stones
a cross at the spirit goes to death and
a cross that a living man may go and
return again if he's a mage by this wall
of stones the man crouched down on the
side of the living and tried to
withstand my will so this is a battle a
struggle of wills
and he could not
he clung to the stones with his hands
and cursed and screamed i have never
seen a fear like that it sickened me
with its own sickness
and here get has a realization now it's
a realization of what he didn't realize
at the time and i think so many of us
can relate to this not in terms of
wizardry but in terms of what we do
when we are enraged he said
i've never seen a see a fear like that
it's sickened me with its own sickness i
should have known by that i did wrong
i was possessed by anger
and by vanity for he was very strong and
i was eager to prove that i was stronger
so ged out of his anger and his wish to
master the master
reduces him to a groveling
husk you could say of a man and he gets
cobb
to
promise of his own free will that he'll
never use the pellish lore again he says
he kissed my hand and would have killed
me if he dared he went from have nor
into the west of palm perhaps i heard
years later he had died he was
white-haired when i knew him and so
uh then
aaron asked well what was his true name
and he said i don't know
they called him cobb in havnor
and so this is this is the character
who's going to turn out to be the
antagonist
in this entire story so ged humiliated
him ged
took the person who was already doing
wrong
and didn't correct him
didn't punish in the right way but
rather retaliated against him
and
cobb is going to go off
perhaps he dies
actually he doesn't instead
he breaches
the
wall the
actually it doesn't breach the wall
itself within the dry land he breaches
the dry land
and the disconnect between living
and death and this is what ged himself
says that he has done
so
reflecting on
him later on
with aaron he says
he had great power it was all bent on
denying death and he knew the great
spells of the lord of paul i was young
and a fool when i used that lore and i
brought ruin on myself
but if an old man and a strong one used
it careless of all consequence he might
bring
ruin
on us all so we go back to the dangerous
nature of the spells of palm you can
bring ruin upon yourself and a few other
people or you can screw things up for
the entire
world
including non-human
entities as well like the dragons as
we're going to find out later on
what else do we learn about cobb
well later on in the story
he is going to appear first with
ascending
and then as a
living person
and then he's going to be dragged again
into the land of the dead where they
they face him and
in the sending
one of the questions that comes up is
well what is your actual name what
should we call you
and
he tells them
here we go
what god says how shall we call you when
we meet you
you will call me lord said the tall
figure on the dunes edge
and what else king and master and he
says and where shall we come to you and
when in my domain and at my pleasure
so he's telling god
i'm beyond you and he's been calling
himself a king to all these other people
ged actually brings up you know the fact
that he's sort of an anti-king when
aaron asks him about that earlier right
when they do wind up in the
land of the dead
there is an exchange where
he asks them what is your name
and cobb says i have none god says all
on this land bear their true name tell
me yours then i am named ged and you the
blind man hesitated and said cobb
god says that was your use name not your
name where is your name where is the
truth of you did you leave it in pain
where you died you have forgotten much
oh lord of the two lands you've
forgotten light and love and your own
true name
and he says i have your name now in
power over you get the ark mage he says
my name's not any of use to you you
can't do anything with it here in the
land of the dead dummy you know and
you know he he he says
who are you you know uh you lost death
you lost life in order to save yourself
yourself your mortal self what is it
who are you and he says i am myself my
body will not decay and die
and get says a living body suffers pain
cub a living body grows old it dies
death is the price that we pay who are
you and finally he says the immortal one
say your name
the king
say my name i told it to you but a
minute since say my name you are not
real you have no name only i exist and
then ged says
you exist
without name without
form
so
it's interesting he has a name cobb
which was that of his past self right
he has
names that are not names but rather
functions or titles king master lord
these these really exchangeable
vocalizations that express dominance and
power and perhaps other things as well
he names himself
finally the immortal one but he's not
really going to turn out to be immortal
after all so
cobb doesn't know who he is cobb doesn't
have what everybody else in earth see
has
a sense of their identity their selfhood
to use a word that ged brought up in
conversation with aaron later
and so
the misuse and it's impossible not to
misuse in a certain respect the pelnish
lore
has gotten him to this point cobb
we never know what his his true name is
all we have is his use name
cobb has become this entity that doesn't
really know itself
you